[Music]
[U. S. Public Health Service in cooperation
with The American Film Center presents]
[About Faces]
[Narrated by Lowell Thomas]
[This picture is made possible thru the generosity of Mr. Cator Woolford of Sterling, Georgia.]
[Produced for the United States Public Health
Service by Sound Masters, Inc.]
[Screen Play Oscar Saul, Direction Owen Murphy]
[Supervision of dental scenes Frank C. Cady, D. D. S., U. S. Public Health Service, J. G. Williams, D. D. S., Georgia Department of Public Health]
[Silence]
[Music]
[Narrator:] Will everybody in the audience
please run the tip of his tongue over his
teeth? In the spirit of the story please.
That's right, thanks.
That's the idea. Thank you.
And what do you find? Anything wrong? Bridgework?
Missing teeth? That's what I thought. Well
that's what the story's about. About teeth.
About Danny Smith's teeth in particular. And
here's Danny applying for an important job.
What do his teeth have to do with it? Well,
are they helping him? Or spoiling his appearance
and his chances? And if they are helping him,
how did they get the way they are? Just look
or what?
[ Animated figure with a camera over his shoulder
running along]
For the answer to that we'll have to go back
through the years to the time when he was
two months old. Not thinking about teeth here.
No teeth to think about.
And there still isn't much doing on the dental
front six months later. When Danny ruled over,
in the order of their appearance, his mother,
his father, and his grandmother- leading the
family group. What's going on here? You two
have discovered something. Can it be that
this is Danny's first --
[Baby Crying and Music]
Yes, that's what it is. Danny's first tooth!
There it is. All alone in [inaudible] and
then comes company.
[Music]
Well, Danny's getting along in years. Here
he is way past two. His mother has planned
her decision. Listen.
[Mrs. Smith:] Doug.
[Mr. Smith:] Yes dear?
[Mrs. Smith:] Let's take Danny to the dentist.
[Mr. Smith:] What's the matter, does he got
a toothache?
[Mrs. Smith:] No, but one of the women took
me to a mother's club meeting the other day
where a dentist spoke. He said that all children
should be taken to the dentist as soon as
their baby teeth cut through the gums.
[Mr. Smith:] Now what could be wrong with
Danny's teeth at his age? Nothing.
[Mrs. Smith:] Well, I still think he ought
to see a dentist. You have some time tomorrow.
Why don't you come along and see what Dr.
Jones has to say.
[Mr. Smith:] I think it's a silly idea. Danny
has better teeth than I have; more of them
too. I say forget the whole thing.
[Music]
[Narrator:] So they went to the dentist.
[Dr. Jones:] How do you do, Mrs. Smith?
[Mrs. Smith:] Good afternoo,n Dr. Jones. My
husband and I would like you to examine Danny's
teeth.
[Mr. Smith:] How do you do, Dr. Jones?
[Dr. Jones:] How do you do, Mr. Smith.
[Mr. Smith:] My wife does insist on having
Danny's teeth examined, although I don't see
why that's necessary. I'm sure there's nothing
wrong with them.
[Dr. Jones:] Maybe not, but we can't be absolutely
sure of that until we've given his teeth a
careful examination. It may even be necessary
to x-ray them.
[Mr. Smith:] X-ray?
[Dr. Jones:] That's right. They're doing a
great deal with x-ray these days. In fact,
I just received a bulletin from the American
Dental Association showing some of their recent
findings. Perhaps you'd be interested in seeing
some of them.
[Mrs. Smith:] I'm sure we would.
[Mr. Smith:] Yes of course.
[Dr. Jones:] It's really amazing the things
they're accomplishing these days. These cavities
were so small that the eye might have missed
them, but they didn't escape the x-ray.
[Mr. Smith:] Yes, but if they're so small
they can't be harmful [inaudible].
[Dr. Jones:] Well, if a cavity is neglected,
it always develops into a large one. Treatment
becomes more unpleasant. Takes more time and
costs more money. Now here. This tooth was
filled as soon as decay appeared. And this
tooth was neglected and the decay spread.
If such a condition is not corrected, it will
result in the loss of the tooth.
[Mrs. Smith:] But is that serious Dr. Jones?
After all, they are only baby teeth.
[Dr. Jones:] Yes they're baby teeth, but they're
very important nevertheless. If they're decayed,
they will interfere with the child's ability
to chew his food and may have a bad effect
on his general health. But that's only part
of the story. Early loss of a baby tooth may
cause the adult teeth to come in crooked.
[Mrs. Smith:] Well, it seems as if the baby
teeth are important after all.
[Mr. Smith:] As usual, my wife was right.
[Dr. Jones:] There is still another important
reason for coming here [in?] time. The child's
first experience with a dentist will be a
pleasant one. It means an examination. Possibly
an x-ray. And a cleaning. Consequently he
won't mind coming for a periodic checkup.
[Mrs. Smith:] I'd like to know if Danny's
teeth are all right.
[Dr. Jones:] Then let's get started.
[Music]
[Narrator:] And Dr. Jones makes friends with
Danny. Makes him feel right at home. Child
psychology they call it nowadays.
[Music]
Danny is at ease. He has complete confidence
in the doctor. The examination is all part
of the fun. Danny enjoys it . And his parents
are relieved, for as Dr. Jones predicted,
Danny's first visit to the dentist has been
a pleasant one.
It will be remembered as good fun. When the
time for the next visit rolls around, four
months from now, Danny won't have to be coaxed
and the visit was an informative one for Danny's
parents. They learned a great many surprising
things about teeth that day.
For instance, Dr. Jones told the Smiths they
could walk along anywhere and stop almost
anybody and find that they have decayed teeth.
Yes, anybody at all.
This young woman for instance. She is unaware
of her neglect, but look. The x-ray reveals
a filling which represents previous decay
taken care of, but here is a new cavity that
needs immediate attention.
What of this enterprising young merchant selling
service with a smile? A happy lad with laughing,
merry eyes. And currently he has rhythm and
maybe a song in his heart.
Woe is the day his teeth have decay. Observe.
The x-ray shows he has a large cavity in a
baby tooth that he will soon lose. And a new
cavity on the biting surface of a second tooth.
Baby teeth growing out. Second teeth coming
in and decay in both. Yes sir, coming and
going.
The doctor told the Smiths, such as this retired
lawmaker, wise enough to make a nation's laws,
but not wise enough to take care of his teeth.
Just roll your eyes over this x-ray. Abscess.
Decay. Anything wrong? Is there anything that
isn't wrong?.
Let's examine the case of this in-a-hurry
gentleman. At one time or another almost everybody
has decayed teeth and what do most of them
do? Well, let's see what he does.
He thinks it over very carefully. Decides
he's too busy to take care of a little cavity.
It doesn't hurt and after all, what's a little
cavity?
Months go by. And a year goes by. And then
what happens? The little cavity has become
a big cavity. And the little pain is a big
pain. So suddenly he's not too busy.
[Music]
He wouldn't bother with a cavity, so he'll
have to bother with bridgework. And he didn't
want to run up a little bill, so now it's
a big bill. After all, what's a little cavity?
Getting back to the Smiths, Dr. Jones told
them there are three ways of brushing teeth.
This way, from side to side. Or the floor
washing method. Very effective for washing
floors.
This is known as the circular or window washing
treatment. Also very effective for washing
windows.
And here's the right way. The upper teeth
are brushed with a downward motion. The lower
teeth with an upward motion. And the chewing
surfaces are brushed by putting the brush
into the grooves and vibrating it backward
and forward. Sounds complicated, but anybody
can learn.
Well, here's Danny again. Eight years old
today. And having himself a time celebrating
the occasion. Danny's building himself up
to a terrific case of odontology. Toothache
to you.
And a toothache by any name hurts just as
much, as Danny is beginning to find out. Teeth
can take so much punishment from sweets.
As we can see in this picture of decay getting
started [in the?] first tooth. Then slowly
cutting through until the tooth has become
infected at the end of the one of the roots.
Yes, Danny doesn't feel so good. He has a
very low opinion of candy at the moment.
It wasn't all the candy's fault, as Mrs. Smith
realizes. She hasn't followed through on Danny's
teeth. She kept the appointments for several
years and then well, like a lot of mothers,
she forgot.
Result? Trouble. Well, better late than never.
But unfortunately it is too late.
Too late to save the infected molar. For Dr.
Jones had to extract it to prevent further
complications. He told Mrs. Smith how serious
an infected tooth can be.
He showed her how decay begins, and when neglected,
penetrates the enamel and attacks the inner
part of the teeth. How, if permitted, the
decay spreads and spreads, sometimes causing
an abcess.
And an abcess like this means going, going
gone. And Mrs. Smith, properly sorry, resolved
that no such neglect would occur again. All
that 16 years ago.
What happened to Danny? Well, our frantic
cameraman brings us up to today. And here
is Danny, a healthy, confident looking young
man of 24.
Here is his mother. A bit older. A bit grayer,
and if possible, a bit prouder of Danny. This
is an eventful day in the Smith household.
And the gay smiles and cheery banter of mother
and son are just make-believe to conceal the
anxiety each feels.
For Danny has an appointment downtown for
a new job that's going to mean a lot to him.
It's the job he was applying for when we first
met him back at the start of the story.
We asked you if his personal appearance would
aid in his landing the job. And what part
his teeth played, and how necessary was it
to take good care of them.
The answers seem pretty obvious in the light
of what we've seen. Good looking teeth and
good looking appearance go hand-in-hand. If
you have any doubts about how strong, healthy
teeth complement a lovely face [inaudible].
This picture is about faces. There is this
young lady. Lovely teeth help make the lady
lovely. Nice teeth always help. We don't appreciate
how essential they are until we make comparisons.
And speaking of comparisons, let's make some.
These gentlemen answer the purpose very well.
Would you say there was competition for Robert
Taylor here? Or here? Or here?
After all, what's a little cavity? And here
is the business appointment that started us
thinking. We sought to prove that good, sound
teeth are a must if we would be healthy.
But they are a must if we value our personal
appearance. We feel Danny has proved the point
of our argument. But what about keeping our
teeth that way? How does Danny handle that
much? Let's see.
Months at the job. Long hours. Hard work.
And lost in the immediate troubles before
him, Danny is forgetting. Forgetting that
important date he has with the dentist on
June 18th.
June 18th, Danny. That's today for the dentist.
Remember? No, he doesn't remember. Well, we've
got some bad news for him.
He doesn't know it yet, but one of his teeth
is beginning to decay. The strange part of
it is, Danny takes [care of?] his teeth.
For example, he eats good, solid food; very
little sweets. But his teeth are decaying
anyway. That's how teeth are. There's no way
of stopping the decay except by going to a
dentist; having it removed, and the tooth
filled.
Danny brushes his teeth every day, and properly
too. But that doesn't stop decay. His teeth
and your teeth need more than a bath. They
need a dentist.
Well, as you guessed, Danny has entirely forgotten
his dental appointment. In his enthusiasm
for the new job, he has fallen into the neglect
common to so many of us.
He just doesn't realize how he'll look if
he loses that tooth. It does make a difference,
doesn't it?
[Music]
Danny is going to be just another man who
wouldn't bother with a little cavity. That
is, unless something happens. Unless something
warns him of the danger. Wow.
Well, Danny got his warning. The cold water
did the trick. And he's lucky it happened
before the decay had gone too far.
Remember the pause that made him remember
he forgot. And before you and I can say, see
your dentist regularly, Danny will be sitting
in the dentist's chair.
And the tooth has been saved. It has a filling,
but it has [inaudible]. And Danny's had a
lesson. He's going to remember to visit the
dentist three times a year.
He's going to remember that regular [inaudible]
treat decay and help guard against the loss
of teeth. That's pretty much the story ladies
and gentlemen.
[Music]
It's the story of Danny Smith. It might have
been the story of you. Or you. Or you. Of
the fellow next door. The girl down the block.
[Music]
It might well be the story of this young man
paying his first visit to the dentist. And
happily bringing our story to the end.
[The End]
[Screen Play--Oscar Saul, Narration--Lowell Thomas, Direction--Owen Murphy]
[Supervised by Ernest R. Bryan, W. Allen Luey, U. S. Public Health Service]
[Technical Consultants:  Frank C. Cady, D. D.
S., U. S. Public Health Service,
J. G. Williams, D. D. S., Georgia Department of Public Health, E. R. Coffey, M. D., U. S. Public Health Service]
[In cooperation with American Film Center]
[Seal of U. S. Public Health Service, 1798]
[Federal Security Agency, Paul V. McNutt,
Administrator. U. S. Public Health Service, Thomas Parran, Surgeon General.]
[Seal of U. S. Public Health Service, 1798]
[From the Film Library of the American Dental
Association, Chicago.]